You are listening to radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
So if we said where we are, I'm on tape yet. Uh,
starting us off today, our producers, Lynn Levy and Sean Cole,
very pretty day to be on an abandoned island where victims of contagious disease
were quarantined. And one in particular who, uh,
lived here, died here.
Never believing that she was in fact sick and dangerous.
No.
So this is the story that she begins where it, well, it's actually,
it starts in 1906 and it doesn't start on the island. It starts in Oyster Bay.
Ooh, nice neighbor. Very nice.
And there was this one rich family on vacation there and their daughter gets
sick. She gets sick first. This is Judy Levitt.
I am a professor Emerita at the University of Wisconsin and she wrote a book
about this story. So basically the girl,
the daughter has a fever than her sister comes down with it.
And then her mom and Umaid about six out of 11 in the family get sick.
And with this disease. The fever is just the first part of it.
Both diarrhea or constipation are reported.
So it can go either way, I guess. What is it? Typhoid
and they couldn't figure out what had caused the disease.
So they called in this sanitary engineer named George Soper with the public
health department. He was the go to guy for outbreaks like this.
Back then the department of public health was thinking,
you know when you get sick because of something dirty near you in the well or in
the pipes. Yeah. So he looks into all of that,
did a whole a test on the house and the water and everything.
Couldn't find anything.
And so he starts talking to the family and he started quizzing them all and they
remember eventually summer he builds up this whole picture of,
of several outbreaks going back year 1900 Mamaroneck on New York family had a
house for the sun. 1902 dark harbor Maine for seven cases,
sands point New York, Autumn 1906 or 1907 in New York City.
All these cases. And they all had one thing in common.
What each of these families had employed.
The same cook is,
which is funny because when you cook food,
you kill the bacteria in the food. Yeah. She couldn't be the cook then,
but this cook, her most famous dish was peach. Melba,
which is ice cream and fresh peaches. Fresh. Yes.
Raw fruit as a perfect medium and the cook's name
was Mary Mallon. Mary man.
Wait a second. Shannon Cole. Typhoid, typhoid Mary. So we're talking about, oh,
so we know this story. No, you don't know this story. What do you mean?
Everybody thinks they know this story.
I thought I knew this and then when I looked into it I realized I didn't know
the first thing about it and when you look into the details,
they tell us some very difficult things about who we were and who we still are.
In a lot of ways. It's all in the details.
All of the juice and problem like an like the, it's like the PQQ. Yeah,
just like the peaches. You still dealing with it. I'm Robert Krulwich. Go ahead.
Go ahead Chad. I have them. Rod, this is radio lab. In this hour,
a series of stories that all hew to that delicious story archetype we call
patient euro.
The first clock we'll try to trace ideas and trends and massive social traumas
like pandemics back to that one person or one critter or the other way you call
it. It's called the bug for if you didn't have this thing,
but for this thing you wouldn't have the rest of this.
I like the button for the button
four.
Meanwhile, back to the peaches. So George Soper is like,
I've got to find this woman. And when he finds her,
she's in New York City working for another family.
The laundry's had recently been taken to the Presbyterian hospital with typhoid
fever.
This is Roman article's super road called the curious case of typhoid Mary and
the only child of the family, a lovely daughter, was dying of it.
So he goes to the house, walks into the kitchen, sees this woman,
five foot six blonde hair, blue eyes, had a good figure.
It might've been called athletic had she not been a little too heavy.
Irish immigrant, 36 years old, not particularly clean. And he says, Mary Mallon,
I think you are causing disease in people and I want, uh,
samples of your urine, feces and blood.
Good afternoon. And she says, what are you accusing me of being sick,
playing the role of Mary is Columbia Public Health Professor David Rosner.
How dare you, I'm not a sick person. What does she do?
She traces them out of the building with that fork in her hand.
A serving fork. A surfing for it. Yeah. I felt rather lucky to escape.
But did she have typhoid? Um, I mean, did she outwardly have typhoid? Well,
that's the thing. She never had any symptoms. She felt perfectly healthy.
She was actually the first documented case in North America of a healthy
carrier,
which is to say someone who has the disease and is contagious but never actually
feels the symptoms, the symptoms. So in one weird way,
sobers thrilled,
like he's only read about this and then here she is in front of him.
But think of how all of this must have sounded. The Mary. I mean,
some guy from outer space comes into your kitchen and says,
you're diseased and you're hurting people. I mean, she must've thought watt.
I feel fine. I'm living a moral life. I'm not a vagrant. I'm employed.
I'm a good solid citizen though you would be crazy to what's your,
even today you'd probably grab your knife. Yeah. You grab your knife.
What does he have any evidence of that? She is spreading the disease. Not yet.
That's why he needs her
poop. Ah,
so he goes back and finds her at a rooming house. She kicks him out,
swears at him. She apparently head quite a temper.
And then the health department, uh, sends in this female doctor
by the name of s Josephine Baker.
Maybe she could ask for blood feces and urine a little more gently.
I don't know how you ask for that gently,
but she tries and when it doesn't work,
she comes back a little bit later with cops and they come to the house and Mary
Mallon, when she realized is what's happening, disappears. May mean disappears,
completely vanishes.
They end up searching the entire place and they can't find it.
Finally,
I think they're about to leave when one of them spots her skirt that coming
outside of a door, it's a little piece of Calico high.
It kind of stuck in a doorway. I opened the door and there she is,
and so they drag her out and she comes out kicking and screaming and screaming.
Chicky takes all of them to drag her out protesting.
They get her in the ambulance at Josephine Baker sits on her according to her,
sits on her and Baker later said something like,
it was like being in a cage with an angry man lion.
So they take her down to the hospital.
They tested her feces and urine and they found that yes,
she was in fact a carrier of live typhoid bacilli
[inaudible]
so weird island man. I spent a while on him.
So they isolate her and they ultimately move her.
Okay. Look for Manhattan too. North brother island.
Let's have a bit of a haunted drive. Yeah, and there she is.
Thanks man. Yeah,
we went there to just to get our heads around what she must have thought.
Let me think. What was the island like and everything is completely overgrown.
It was really creepy. Creepy because it was in such dissolution. Yeah.
Yes. Be careful where you step and one end. There are all of these medical,
former medical buildings,
including a giant hospital where they isolated tuberculosis patients.
So big brick, stately building. And then on the other side of the island,
there's smaller wooden buildings that are crushed.
This may maybe where her cottages,
where her cottage would be if it was still standing,
but it's not standing anymore. Well, it was one room, one room.
Uh, I had a kitchen. It had a, I guess asleep sleeping
area and a sitting area. It probably wasn't,
so if you didn't have to stay there, you know,
any places that you're not free to leave of becomes like a prison.
Okay.
So we're marching around and then Lynn says to me, hey,
look at the view and holy Moly,
take a look. It's right there. That's when it really hit me.
If this is where her cabin was,
then one window of it looked exactly on the Manhattan.
She could have seen where she used to live.
You can see the traffic on the streets.
Okay.
This was like the most horrible seaside vacation almost the whole time they had
her incarcerated. They took feces three times a week, which is, you know,
it's not pleasant to have to do that. Um,
and sometimes she was negative and sometimes she was positive. Wait, what?
So that's, that's another thing that they were figuring out at the time.
So she was probably an intermittent carrier. What does that mean?
The disease is always in her,
but sometimes she excretes it and sometimes she doesn't. Oh,
that must have been confusing for her. When I first came here,
I was so nervous and almost prostrated with grief and trouble.
My eyes began to twitch. This is from a letter that Mary wrote from the island.
I have in fact been a peep show for everybody. But if you keep reading it,
and in fact it's addressed to a lawyer,
it's clear that she was fighting this and she had been sending her own feces
samples herself to a private lab in Manhattan and each one of those was
negative. Really? The tuberculosis men would say there she is
the kidnapped woman. Yeah, that is poison ivy.
She sees the city and loses still.
There are all these questions as to whether any of this is legal.
I mean even George Soper,
the guy who hunted her down said it was contrary to the constitution of the
United States to hold her under the circumstance.
And how long was she on the silent? For three years. Wow.
And then what changed was a new health commissioner took over.
And so he says it's just not right that we keep a healthy woman locked up like
this. She was not dangerous to anybody. If she didn't cook,
he lets her go. He lets you go back to Manhattan. But he makes her promise.
She did promise. She signed an affidavit saying she'll never cook again.
And she was released. They gave,
they've set her up with a job as a laundress and they rent. Here you go Mary.
And then, uh, you know, they kept track of her for awhile.
Uh, and then at a certain point they kinda stopped keeping track over
[inaudible] time. So how many years will go by?
Five. Five. What happens next?
There's an outbreak of typhoid where we're at a maternity hospital.
You're kidding. Josephine Baker,
who sat on her in the ambulance before she says that she goes and pays a visit
and walks into the kitchen and she says the first person that she encountered
was typhoid Mary Mallon
[inaudible]
George Soper did some leg work on where Mary had been.
And it turned out she had worked at a restaurant, two hotels and in,
and a sanitorium as well as the hospital. Wow.
And at least according to his account,
two of the people that she made sick during those couple of years were children
[inaudible].
She was now a woman who could not claim innocence.
She was known willfully and deliberately to have taken desperate chances with
human life. She had abused her privilege. She had broken her parole.
So then they put her back on north brother island back in her bungalow. Um,
and there she sits.
She was a dangerous character and must be treated accordingly. Absolutely.
She's booked broker problem line. Totally B.
She made a deal and she didn't keep the deal.
But the thing is is that at the time she was sent back to the island,
there were hundreds of other healthy carriers identified all over New York and
some of them were cooks. What? Most really? Mostly men by the way.
And they were cooking while they were barred from cooking,
but not all of them always listened. Huh.
And yet Mary was the only one who they isolated in this way.
Why?
Why only her?
I think it was more about making people feel safe than actually making them
safe. Oh, look out for this stare. Saul crumbled.
She was what we needed at the time
were in the hospital where the tuberculosis patients were quarantined.
This was towards the end of linen. My visit to the island.
Yeah. These must be the words. Definitely. Yeah.
So when was she here?
This is where they brought her after she had a stroke
and this is where she was for the last six years of her life.
Did she die in here? Yeah.
Yeah.
Hi, this is David Roster. [inaudible] reading this message.
Radiolab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology. For instance,
technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org Radiolab is produced by WM YC and
distributed by NPR. Okay, that's it. Thanks. Bye.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by Sofi, a new
kind of finance company. Here's the deal.
If you've invested in your career by taking out student loans,
Sofi wants to help out sofi, refinances,
federal and private student loans to cut interest rates and save its members an
average of $316 a month.
Learn more and find your savings at s o f [inaudible] dot com terms and
conditions apply at sofi.com/legal
hi, this is Kevin Murray from Fort Collins, Colorado.
Radiolab is supported by Fox searchlight pictures presenting Jackie from
Director Pablo The rain and starring Natalie Portman as the iconic first lady.
Then Jacqueline Bouvier Kennedy. In the days following the assassination of JFK,
Natalie Portman delivers another Oscar caliber performance and a film that
reimagines the events through the eyes of Jackie herself as she fights to cement
her husband's historical legacy in select theaters. Now,
hey guys, this is Alison calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandmlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab and today it's patient zero.
I've tried subject, yeah, and this next story, oh, it's so huge.
It's the ultimate patient zero story. Really many of us have lived through this.
It was, it's as recent in event.
It's such a recent event that it still hurts and it still bleeds. Yeah,
and in it somewhere is a literally the,
the patient that is called zero. So this is, yeah.
A lot of people are going to help us tell the story,
but starting us off is science writer, radio lab, regular Carl Zimmer.
So in 1981
doctors for the first time describe mysterious,
newly discovered disease syndrome, which affects mostly homosexual men.
The young men in Los Angeles are dying.
The number of cases has been growing faster and faster.
So far more than 80 Americans have died. 258 people have died.
625 people have died. Of course,
this is the part we all know how from the first few cases in La aids became one
of the deadliest pandemics the world has ever seen.
It more dangerous than the plague of the Middle Age ages.
The back of the beginning there was a story that I have not been able to shake
for the last 30 years and it's a story and I want to reimagine right now
[inaudible]
right after news of this syndrome started to break that science writer,
David [inaudible], who along with Carl will be one of our guides.
Epidemiologists were trying to figure out where did it come from and they were
thinking like, well, maybe it's a sexually transmitted disease.
So the CDC launches a study of a group of about 30 patients,
gay men in New York, Los Angeles,
and San Francisco to see who had had sexual contact with whom.
How do you get the SF? Just a series of interviews with people. Yeah,
please name all the people that you, that you've slept with.
The CDC eventually releases the results of this survey in the form of a diagram
like a network drawing with circles representing patients in lines representing
sexual contact in each patient. Each little circle was numbered,
New York seven Los Angeles 12 so you didn't know who was who,
but you could tell immediately when you look at this thing,
that of all the 30 or so circles, there was one circle that was special.
It had lines coming out in every direction,
seven or eight emanating from him like the hub of a wheel except all the spokes
on this wheel connected to other wheels which then shot out and connected to
other wheels fanning outward at the center of it all was that one little circle
numbered
zero number zero
as far as we know,
that was the first time that you ever get the term patient zero.
Patient zero was on my app, a central victim and victimizer.
This is from a 60 minutes special. In 1988 that year,
a reporter named Randy Schultz had written a book called and the band played on
that for the first time revealed the identity of patient zero.
He was a French Canadian or very handsome Caroline Stewart named gates.
Don Duga. Gates do [inaudible] zero
a few minutes later in the report, Shults comes on to this.
Describe a guy who has got unlimited sexual stamina,
this
sexual athletes who would fly from one hotspot to the next because of this job
having sex with literally thousands of men and as he knew he was dying,
at least according to Randy Shields, he became somewhat sinister and malicious.
He would sleep with a male partner at a bathhouse in San Francisco or somewhere
else, and then when the light came up, according to Randy Shields, he would say,
I've got gay cancer
now. You're going to get it to your doctor. I talked to him. Yeah.
This is Dr Selma drips. She was part of that CDC. Yes.
I told him that he was getting other people sick with it and he said,
my right to do whatever I want by civil rights.
I do as I pleased. I've got it. Why shouldn't they have it? They said,
you can kill yourself if you want the did you cut? No.
Right to take somebody else along with you and you said, screw you,
and walked out.
Really a chilling moment.
[inaudible]
and pretty much from that moment on Gayton Douga he just took on this,
this aura as as single handedly causing a, a,
an epidemic in the United States. Now, I don't know about you,
but I first bumped into this story in the movie version of an,
the band played on my friend, we're talking about thousands of men was faces,
I cannot even remember. And you want names. That's an actor playing,
kicking the gun, the movie. Now,
when I first saw that aids had already infected two and a half million people,
and to think that it could all go back to this one guy just seemed
unreal. It was a, it was a very, a potent story. There's no doubt
[inaudible]
and, and he gave HIV to a lot of people. There's no question about that.
But what we do know is that he was not patient zero.
He was not patients here. No, he was not the beginning point.
He was not even close. Huh?
So here's the question that got me started in the story. The, okay,
so the gay steward, that was the movie stuck in my head.
But what's the real movie?
What movie can we make about the beginning of the AIDS epidemic?
Because when you've got something so vast that according to some mass estimates
will have killed 60 million people by the end of the decade.
What you need a beginning.
You need some way of explaining how this disaster happened and how it might
happen again.
And how exactly do we know that Gayton Dugo wasn't patient's hero? Well,
um, there are a couple of reasons we know it. So, um,
so one thing that people started to do, scientists was to, um,
they went and started going back and looking at people who had died or who died
mysteriously aids like things in the past might,
some of them have been early cases and they started finding a lot.
Robert Rayford had aged 12 years before it was recognized in this country.
In 1959, a sailor in Britain died of pneumocystis pneumonia.
And so for awhile you had all these new patients, Zeros. In 1961,
a nurse in Chicago died of Kaposi Sarcoma.
But the real definitive blow to this.
So patient zero nonsense came by. Actually looking at the virus itself
in 1984, same year that gate into God died.
Scientists isolate the virus HIV,
which is really just a little string of genetic code that gets into your body
and into your cells and uses your cells to make copies of itself.
But here's the thing, when it replicates within a single patient,
it copies itself. Um, in precisely,
it mutates
quickly.
It changes a lot as the virus duplicates itself inside a person,
the dukes often have little copying errors and that middle mutations,
it turns out those errors, they happen at a predictable rate.
You can kind of almost predict how many you're going to see a year or five
years. And so the amount of changes that you see out there,
the diversity really of the viruses in the aids population,
well that becomes really good information.
And so a group of scientists began to look at the amount of diversity among HIV
patients in the u s and other parts of the world.
And the more diversity the longer the virus has been around. Right? Right.
And they could use that kind of like a clock.
If you have a virus here and a virus there,
you could measure how different they are and you would know
that it would take a certain amount of time for them to get that different.
And to make a long story short,
the picture they get is that aids entered the United States around 1966
at a time when Gaten two guy was still a virgin adolescent.
From there, scientists were able to trace the virus back to Haiti
and from Haiti back to Africa.
It's been there the longest. It's had the longest time to become diverse,
to mutate, to evolve. So if you want to really, if you want to get to the,
to the real patients, your as it were,
the most interesting stuff come actually comes from Africa.
So one way to try to figure out its origins there is to go looking for the
virus.
Yup.
And that takes us back to Zr 59 and DRC 60 can we talk about damn sure what
these are the two earliest known HIV positive human specimens.
And this is where, for me at least,
the story gets way bigger than I imagined from the first sample.
Zr 59 came to light in the late nineties somehow scientists unearthed a very old
tube of blood from a hospital in Kinshasa in the Democratic Republic of Congo,
and when they tested it,
it had HIV.
This had been taken from a band to man in 1959 1959 right?
Yeah. Nobody knows his name. Nobody even knows I think what he died of,
and that was the only one for a number of years.
That was our one glimpse into the kind of deep history of HIV. Yeah.
But then along comes that Guy Michael Warby.
He's an evolutionary biologist at the University of Arizona and a few years ago
Michael went back to Kinshasa and found a second HIV sample.
He actually found the virus lurking in a tiny bit of human tissue that was
preserved in paraffin wax.
It's kind of like a Hans Solo in a, in the star wars movie,
when he's kind of frozen in that carbonite or whatever that stuff is
in this new sample,
it was from the same town can show asa is the first and also more importantly
from the same time
1960 and with the two of them then you can kind of go back in time.
That's so yes, like we described before,
you can measure the differences between the samples,
calculate how long it would take for those samples to get that different.
And in the end you can use these two samples to wind the clock all the way back
to the virus. It started at all and it turned out
the most recent common ancestor of those two specimens goes back to about 1908
1908 that is when it started in human beings.
What 1908 77 well roughly give or take a margin of error early 19 hundreds wow.
So around 1908 give or take
something happened. That's right.
That moment is the spillover spill over spillovers the term the scientists use
to describe the moment when a virus in one species passes into another species.
Yeah.
Know new diseases in humans tend to pop up from
animals.
So people said, okay, flu comes from birds. Where does HIV come from to get it?
Then answer, you have to look beyond human beings.
You have to look at other viruses that are like HIV.
So the search was on the inability to find a similar disease and research
animal. Turns out right about the time that the HIV virus was discovered.
Scientists at the New England primate research center,
some researchers found a virus like it in the CAC monkey monkey. In fact,
it was so similar that they called it
Sib Simeon. Immuno
efficiency virus. Yes. And that's where the origin quest started.
This is Beatrice Hahn.
I'm a professor of medicine and microbiology at the University of Pennsylvania.
And so after they found it, macaques, what happened? Um,
it took a couple of years,
but eventually she says they found Siv instill another primate species to Sooty
mangabey.
And then in a few more African green monkeys mandrill pretty soon it was all
over the place.
Now I think 40 different species of African monkeys known to have their own
version of Siv. So then the question was,
which one of these monkeys or primates pass it to us? Then unexpectedly,
a researcher named Martine Martine Peters at the center in gumball decided to
test her chimps who? Orphan chimpanzees and Bingo.
She found a very, very close match,
a virus that was the closest relative of HIV one. So everybody said, well,
you know, it was a CIM. It was a gym. Okay, yeah. It came from chimp. Yes.
But then the question was which chimps or rather where,
where exactly.
So Beatrice Hahn and her colleagues started looking at chimps that came from
different parts of western Central Africa.
Now getting blood samples from chimps in the wild is pretty much,
it just isn't feasible, you know,
because in the wild they hide the moment they see us.
So you get stuck with fecal samples, poop? Oh yes.
There's lots of DNA in there in viruses.
So they would just go to where the chimpanzees would sleep at night and they
would just, you know, collect some poop,
bring it back to the lab and Beatrice would analyze all the viruses over 90
different wild communities from every part of central Africa,
over 7,000 different fecal samples.
And slowly they were able to piece together which communities were infected and
which ones had the closest HIV one. That's when it hit us for the first time.
What exactly hit you? The geographic origin of these chimps?
In 2006 her and her colleagues published that the human aids virus comes from a
group of chimps,
a very specific group that live in a very specific place.
This little corner of southeastern camera between the boom bar river,
Goco river, and the Sangha River.
These chimps were essentially penned in between these three rivers scenario.
Probably only have a hundred square miles. Not much more than that. Wow.
So when we're looking at what humans have,
and we're looking at what all of those chimps in Africa have,
the most perfect match is this little territory up there in Cameron.
Yeah. There is no other virus that is any closer. So that's that.
So can you reconstruct the spillover and the WHO that it spilled over into?
As you know, as best as you can understand,
it can hypothesize and the best hypothesis is the cut hunter hypothesis.
The cut hunter cut hunter. That's right. A hunter who gets cut.
And what can we say about this guy? I mean, is he, what do we know about,
if we had to guess, if we had to guess that
human was probably a band too, man.
Okay.
Living very near the forest or in the forest and southeastern camp. Yeah,
he was hunting.
Maybe he had a bow and arrow. Maybe he had a spear
and uh,
kills the tumor.
Bingo. Here's a big pile of me and he starts to butcher.
He's cutting open the chest cavity. He's pulling out organs and
he cuts himself and he gets blood to blood contact chimpanzee blood against his
blood.
What happens is that the virus in the chimpanzee blood found itself in an
environment that was unexpected, that was alien to it,
but was not too much different from the biochemical environment.
It had been in chimpanzee blood.
It could function and that's the moment. That's the moment it begins.
That human is patient zero, but why then?
Why 1908 I mean presumably people who have been hunting ships for a really long
time, why wouldn't this guy be patient 7 million?
That's another of the big questions.
People certainly in central Africa have been eating. Yeah,
monkeys for thousands of years. I mean,
David says there's really no way to know,
but this could've just been the right virus. Maybe this particular virus. Yeah,
evolved in a way that made it more transmissible in humans
or maybe it just got lucky to come along at precisely the right time.
What you're looking at, this is Carl again,
is a time when this part of Africa was being heavily colonized.
The French and the Belgians were building trains systems.
The populations were on the move Kinshasa, which was then Leopoldville.
It was exploding. It was huge.
The cities were attracting people from the boonies in those days.
Just so by 1908,
all the virus has to do is get from that tiny village where the cut hunter lived
to one of the new cities that happens almost certainly by river.
Mm.
I was stirred by the work of Beatrice on and Mike Warby to see what this
scenario looked like on the ground.
So I went to southeastern Cameron and I chartered a little boat about a 30 foot
wooden boat with an outboard, any
trace, the path of the virus.
We went down the end Goco river and we stopped at a few villages.
There are a couple of little villages there,
one of which has a market where you can buy um,
monkey meat and crocodile meat.
And he says it wasn't hard to imagine how it all might've went down.
Perhaps the cut hunter gave the virus to a woman who then passed it on to a
fisherman fellow that I called the voyager, who then got in a boat his David did
and carried it down the river. Tsonga River, which is the,
the in Goco is a tributary of the Sanga.
Tsonga becomes a bigger river 200 meters wide,
which then flows to the Congo river, the big river, and into the city.
And I imagine him sliding into Brazzaville
around 1920 the first HIV positive man to arrive in an urban center where
there's a much greater density of humans,
where there prostitutes a greater fluidity of social and sexual interactions.
And that seems to have been the place from which the disease went globally.
So that's how it happened.
[inaudible]
we can take it back even farther actually. What do you mean
for our kids? If you want to make a movie about this start of it.
Well this is not the start because we got it from chimps. Right? Right.
So you could ask her who was chimps zero, what do we know about chimps? Zero,
right? Yeah. I mean everything comes from somewhere. And again,
by molecular work scientists,
have they been able to determine that the chimp virus is actually,
it actually comes from two monkey viruses,
two different monkeys from two completely different species.
What would they have encountered each other somewhere or had a fight with a,
they probably encountered each other in the stomach of a chimp.
Meaning what? Well, from the perspective of a chimpanzee monkeys,
they look tasty. This is Nathan Wolfe,
professor in human biology at Stanford University and he says,
to fully understand this part of the patient to a rather chimp zero narrative,
you have to grasp how it is that chimps hunt.
And this is something he witnessed in the Kabali national forest in,
in southwestern Uganda.
Can
you describe to US watching three male chimps converge on a tree?
Fourth column, this monkeys, which are those race? No, black and white.
And one individual managed to grab to juvenile.
And then the three individuals all up [inaudible]
began to eat. The monkey was still alive.
The chimpanzee was going after in Oregon. You know, the, that obviously was a,
a tasty morsel that, that he was going after and, and the monkey was, uh,
was screaming bloody murder. It is quite disturbing to watch,
he says, but the one of the things that struck me at that moment,
oh,
was the depth of contact between the blood and body fluids of this monkey and
the chimpanzee.
The chimps are literally covered in blood and blood on their face and in their
eyes. And from the viruses perspective,
this is spillover heaven. Okay.
So the following is the closest that we can get to a zero point in this entire
narrative. We don't know where it happened and we don't know exactly the time.
Say some hundreds of thousands of years ago from the molecular clock.
We know it was less than a million years. That's all we know.
But whenever it was chimp's zero was hunting and it comes upon a monkey called a
red cap. Mangabey the the redcap Mangabey. This is, uh,
a larger primate and these are treated dwelling. Little,
little guys treat dwelling a little bit of red for on their heads. Yes. Chips,
zero spots. One of these monkeys eats it.
And in the process key catches a red cap. Mangabey version of the AIDS virus.
Next sometime after that first kill weeks,
months, we don't know, maybe it was the same day.
Chimp zero comes across another monkey and this monkey, it was called a spot.
Knows Gwen it. Yes, it's got a spot on it snows, I assume. There you go.
Very small.
One of the tiniest monkeys of all of the old world monkeys and chips.
Zero eats that monkey
and gets a spot nose Guinen version of the AIDS virus for the HIV virus inside.
So you've got the red cap man could be,
and you've got the spot knows Gwen ens who've got a Quentin and a Mangabey,
two completely different
kinds of Siv viruses inside the same chimp. Now,
under normal circumstances, according to Nathan,
both of these Siv viruses would go
nowhere because one, one of these viruses makes the jump.
They go from a place they've adapted to and that they know to a completely
foreign landscape, uh, like a human being dropped off on Mars.
Maybe without a spacesuit.
I mean they basically are entering a completely alien habitat.
The cells don't look the same.
The environment is different and the chimps immune system would normally kill
them. But then once in a blue moon, something crazy happens.
These two
viruses will end up inside the same cell,
in the same chimp at the same time.
Literally there is a single cell simultaneously infected with both viruses to
suppose on one side of the cell you've got the mangabey virus,
mommy, mommy, Mama, Mama,
and on the other side of the same cell, you've got the spot nose Gwen and virus.
And what happens is, uh, literally inside the cell you have
an enzyme,
it's called the preliminary enzyme that's copying genetic information to the
virus. This is what viruses do.
They hijack these enzymes to make copies of themselves.
No,
here's the problem. These, these enzymes,
they're not necessarily that sticky and while they're in the process of copying
one virus, every once in awhile they'll accidentally fall off,
make copy,
and go back and latch on to the second virus and just keep on copying.
And so what it ends up spitting out is a hybrid
like that.
No, this new mosaic probably won't go anywhere because
99.9999999999% of the [inaudible]
time when these hybrids happens, a dead end,
the chimps immune system is pretty sophisticated.
It has evolved defenses against these viruses and it will destroy them,
but again, once in a blue moon,
so this is a blue moon after blue moon after a blue moon to really get this.
Finally you get one particular mosaic virus,
no
clean, the mangabey and the and that through sheer random luck
works for me.
It landed on the exact right combination of genes that allowed it to evade the
chimp's immune system. I mean,
one of the amazing things to think about is how many,
how many hopeful monsters you had to have in order to get that one that actually
survived probably trillions, but then boom,
suddenly in a flash from these two viruses that can barely survive in the chimp,
you get a new virus a little bit mangabey little bit.
Quintin cannot only survive and the chimp, but can thrive.
In fact for this baby virus,
the chimp is the perfect host and that was the virus that ended up spreading,
jumping over into humans
and it's been this massive and incredibly dramatic sort of tear in the fabric of
humanity.
Ah,
let me add another parentheses.
There are essentially 12 major groups of the HIV virus.
What David means is it 12 different kinds of HIV viruses have spilled over 12
different
times. Eight of them came from monkeys,
three of them came from chimps and one came from gorillas. Wow.
And of those 12 only one of them is responsible for the global pandemic.
How there 12 kinds 12 times that we know about,
it's probably happened dozens and dozens more times that we don't know about.
So the spillover is not a highly improbable event.
These sorts of viruses,
they're constantly paying at us, they're pinging at us and pinging it at us.
We see it happening all the time. You see it happening all the time.
Nathan has set up a series of monitoring stations in places like central Africa
and he and his colleagues have been tracking what he calls the viral chatter.
In the people who hunt these primates,
we collected specimens from the animals that they were hunting.
They compare that to blood samples from the hunters themselves. And guess what?
We found a whole range of new retroviruses that we're moving over into these
hunters. For example,
he's been tracking something called the Simian foamy virus,
which is first in the same family as HIV and he has seen it hot from an
individual gorilla to an individual human who killed that gorilla. Yeah.
These are almost certainly what we call primary transmission events. Oh,
so you really are looking at the potential beginning of something. Yes.
You want a patient zero and really clear patient zero a,
it's some of these individuals that have been affected with these viruses.
And the real question is how do we stop patients Zeros?
How do, how do we avoid patient, the patient one and patient two. Exactly.
So Nathan is developing a series of tools like digital surveillance. I mean,
some of these places
I work in some places in Democratic Republic of Congo,
you basically have to fly in to get there. No roads, often, no electricity.
Okay.
But many of these places, they still have cell phone towers.
So Nathan has begun to track cell phone call patterns in these communities.
So if he sees a blip of many calls to a medical center within a short period of
time, okay, boom.
Now we've got to investigate that and we continue to find viruses that are
completely novel and we're looking to determine if these are,
if these are the next HIV cause.
Thinking about he says HIV landed in humans in 1908 but we didn't know about it
until 1981 we had decades of time when this was a virus before it spread
globally. What if we'd been looking for it?
[inaudible]
a lot of people to thank for this segment,
thanks to Nathan Wolf for being Nathan and he has an awesome new book called the
viral storm. Also,
thank you to Carl Zimmer whose book on viruses is called a planet of viruses and
thank you also to him and to Michael Warby.
Their interview was recorded on a podcast from meet the scientist, which you can
find@microbeworld.org and thanks to David Coleman,
who's got a book called spillover coming out very soon,
which is all about diseases crossing over from animals to us and also to
Beatrice Hahn at the University of Pennsylvania and to Katie Slocombe from the
University of York for letting us use her recordings of chimpanzees.
No.
Hey, this is Soren wheeler, senior editor and producer at Radiolab, uh,
with a quick update. Um,
so David Commons books spillover is spin out for a couple of years now and as we
all know, we are actually now at this moment facing the tragic
consequences of another spillover this time it's the Ebola virus and we found
ourselves wondering just how far it's going to spill. Okay. All right.
Okay. And Jane. So Robert and I called up David Coleman again.
He had actually just reprinted with updates,
the chapter about a bullet from his book. Yeah. Ebola,
the natural and human history of a deadly virus. First of all,
how old is this disease? Anyone have any idea?
Well as a human disease. As far as we know,
it dates to 1976 there was this outbreak of a strange disease at the young Buku
mission in northern Zaire. 318 cases,
280 people die and then there was another one in Sudan at about the same time.
This time 151 people die and then it just disappears.
Hiding in the forest without a trace until 1994 1994 thousands of miles away in
Gabon, another outbreak. Yes. That's what, that's the history.
Since 1976 it disappears for for two or three years at a time.
Sometimes it disappears for a decade and then it spills over and causes a human
outbreak. Well, if,
if something is in the closet and there's going to jump out at you,
then the natural question to ask is, where's the closet? Like,
where is it hiding? Uh, well, the,
the main suspects are bats.
We don't know that for sure because nobody has ever isolated live Ebola virus
from an African Bat. Have they tried,
have they looked in lots and lots of Baghdad? They've looked into lots.
They've looked in all kinds of animals. They've looked in insects,
they've looked in snakes, they've looked in forest antelopes,
they've looked in monkeys. They looked in plants.
Literally hundreds of different species. They looked in,
found zero traces of live Ebola virus,
so we really don't know where it's coming from or where it might come from next.
No, no.
Can I just ask you just to describe the Bolo virus? It's a,
it's apparently viruses are generally teeny. Is this a teeny, teeny, teeny one?
Yes. Yeah. It's a teeny virus. It belongs to a family.
They call the Filo viruses. Filo has in thread, it's a,
it's a spaghetti shaped virus.
It's genome is carried on just one strand of the,
the genetic material R, n a.
And while those genes have let the virus live happily for hundreds of thousands,
even millions of years in baths or whatever animal it lives in,
when it gets into humans, Ebola Burns too hot.
It makes so many copies of itself so quickly that it just destroys the body and
the person is usually dead within a few weeks,
which David says is actually bad for the virus because Ebola can only pass
through direct contact with bodily fluids. And because it kills so quickly,
it doesn't have a lot of opportunities to get into the next person.
So the scientists have a term for that too.
They call at least they used to call us a dead end host.
How's that for a phrase where the dead end host of Ebola.
And that means that when Ebola gets into us, it has no great future.
It's either going to burn out and come to an end or we're going to stop it. Uh,
but right now we don't seem like a dead end host. I, I'm wondering like,
you know, if we've,
if since we've started noticing in 1976 so a burst here at burst there,
why, why now?
This wise is the big question for Ebola.
2014 this time we've got a very different situation. It's gotten out of control.
Why has it gotten out of control? Well,
partly because we recognized it late.
It began back in December of 2013 with a two year old boy in southeastern
Guinea. At least he's the first known case at this point. He died.
His mother died about a week later, his sister died. His grandmother died.
Other people in the village died.
This went on from early December until the middle of March.
By then had spread from these small villages into larger cities. In Part,
David says, because, well, previous outbreaks had been in very remote places.
It now found itself in a more densely populated area.
The capital cities in these small West African countries are not very many miles
away from the villages of the countryside.
And then the virus got into these poor neighborhoods like west point, uh,
where people were living together in crowded slum like neighborhoods.
And, uh, and when their loved ones got sick, the people took care of them.
And when their loved ones died, people cleaned the bodies and,
and touched the bodies and said goodbye to them.
So the infection spread and of course those,
those dense poor neighborhoods in the capital cities are not that far from the
international airports.
So suddenly you've got the opportunity for the almost the first time for Ebola
to get on an airplane. So if you,
if is have people changed the way they think about Ebola because I mean as,
is there a mood shift there? There's a little bit of a mood shift, but the,
the experts, the scientists,
public health officials are still saying this is not that kind of virus.
It's still is as far as we know,
a virus that is only transmissible by direct contact with bodily fluids.
It should be easy to stop, easy to contain. But according to David,
the thing that some scientists are worried about is that as Ebola gets into more
and more people and makes more and more copies of itself, it's changing. Yes.
Every time it replicates, there is a chance of a mistake.
There's a chance that the genes for the next virus will come out just a little
bit different. It'll mutate.
Most mutations are either insignificant or they do damage,
but occasionally there can be a mutation that might possibly help the virus.
Can we track these things? Like can we,
can we take a person who's got sick of Ebola and Sudan?
I compare it to a person who's sick,
have a bullet in the Congo and compare that to a person who's sick of it.
Bullet and Niger and wherever. Can we do that and see whether it's changing?
Yes, and it has been done.
Steven Guyer and his colleagues published a paper in science in early September,
which involved doing exactly that.
And one of the things they found says David is that since this virus has been in
us during this outbreak,
it's been changing twice as fast as it has previously when it's living in his
animal hiding place. Yeah.
So it has had more opportunities to replicate in more different people.
It hasn't just been in 300 people,
it's been in 9,000 people now that is that the key word is that the more
opportunities you have to have a good mutation from your point of view,
that this is suddenly,
this disease has gotten an enormous number of opportunities.
And that is the operative word. Yeah. Are there boundaries around that?
I mean like do we have any sense of how big a leap it would be for this to
suddenly be transmissible in the air? Yeah,
we know that for this to spread through the air, uh,
they're very special machinery. You know, grappling hooks,
proteins on the outside of a virus that help it catch hold of particular cells
and enter them.
And Ebola doesn't have the right grappling hooks to lay hold of cells in the
respiratory tract and get in them and then come bursting out of them and be
carried out.
Word on your breath to get to that point would require a number of mutations,
each of which is infant's decimally unlikely.
And when you is that applying mutation that it would be startling like Oh,
what to, oh, what, what was, yeah. Some people have been saying that, uh,
it would be like mutations that allowed a giraffe to fly,
but there are other scenarios that are a little more probable. Uh, for instance,
it might, uh,
mutate and adapt in such a way that it kills fewer people or kills them more
slowly and leaves people infectious for a longer period of time.
Maybe people are walking around, uh,
for three or four weeks with an occasional vomiting episode,
but they're not dying.
That would potentially give Ebola a greater opportunity to spread among more
people. What has, this is not a fair question to ask you,
but what should we be doing?
I think the most important thing we should be doing is not letting the public
health versus civil civil liberties issues in the u s distract us from West
Africa as the case count gets. We've talked about this.
As the case count gets higher,
it has more opportunities to mutate and therefore more opportunities to adapt.
So we need to end this outbreak in west Africa before this virus learns too much
about us.
[inaudible]
thanks again to David Kwaman. His book, uh, is Ebola,
the natural and human history of a deadly virus. We'll be back in just a moment.
My name is Brennan Novak and I'm calling from Reykjavik Iceland.
We're about half the country believes in elves.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
handsome public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is supported by Morgan Stanley.
Your son has a gift for gymnastics.
Your daughter has her eye on a little startup in the valley and you want to
retire early. Now,
how do you create a wealth plan that reflects all the complexity of a modern
family?
Start with a financial advisor who understands individuals and knows how to
bring families together around both shared and personal goals.
More information@morganstanley.com slash conversations Morgan Stanley Smith,
Barney, LLC, members civic.
Hi, this is Kevin Murray from Fort Collins, Colorado.
Radiolab is supported by Fox searchlight pictures presenting Jackie from
director Pablo the rain and starting Natalie Portman as the iconic first lady.
Then Jacqueline Bouvier Kennedy in the days following the assassination of JFK,
Natalie Portman delivers another Oscar caliber performance in a film that
reimagines the events through the eyes of Jackie herself as she fights to cement
her husband's historical legacy in select theaters. Now,
hey, you want to know about my, one of my proudest moments of being a dad? Yeah.
Happened this morning. Yeah.
So you know how a meal is a little bit of an introvert, right?
When we sort of worried whether he socializes enough, well,
we were taking him to daycare and uh, we're getting,
he's taking his shoes off and there's this little boy who's only there two days
a week and he's not adjusting well. And every time his mother drops him off,
she has to literally pry him off her and he's wailing and you know,
so a meal sits down on this little seat to take a shoes off.
The mother of this kid puts this little boy next to a meal and he is just
crying. He's distraught.
So then what happens is a meal turns to this little boy looks at him,
sticks out his hand and says I five
out of nowhere. And that is amazing. Yeah. Because it's like they're,
they're out in their own society, you know? Yeah.
Okay. So let's do the introductions. I'm, I'm Jad Robert. This is radio lab.
We're calling this show patient zero. Yeah. And for this next segment,
no more patients. No more diseases. Exactly.
Let's focus instead on invention on the people who bring new ideas into the
world. Yeah. The behind the ideas.
That doesn't quite sound right. You know what I mean? Yeah.
And that guy you just heard,
hi, my name is John McClellan.
I'm a contributing writer at the New York Times magazine.
He's got his own high five story to tell though. It's not about his daughter.
We have, I think we have kids around the same age. His or her first high five.
It's actually about the first high five ever.
Ever. Yeah. See One morning, a few years ago,
2007 or 2008 John turned on his computer, opened up his email and found
a press release about the, the true undisputed inventor at the high five coming,
you know, out final, who was the press release from national high five day,
which is a kind of a joke holiday that was invented by a group of high school
friends, I think. And they told the story, they told the story of Lamont sleep.
So
with college basketball player, Murray State and Kentucky,
and the story in the press release with something like this sleets,
his father fought in Vietnam as part of the first battalion
fifth infantry, which was nicknamed the five.
And they used to greet each other by holding up their hand and saying five as a
kind of prideful. And when Lamont was younger,
they would all sort of hang out at the house in Kentucky and he couldn't keep
all their names straight. So when they'd walk in the door and go five,
he would just sort of smack their hands.
They go high five Oh, like hi, like hello five hello? Five. Yeah. Hi Comma,
five you know, he has small hands,
he likes to put them up against the big hands of the five guys.
And it was years later that he started playing college basketball at Mary's
state and started high fiving all his teammates.
He didn't really never stopped high fiving, it was just something he did.
But when he went around playing away games,
other teams picked it up and it sort of spread out.
So he was sort of both the inventor of the [inaudible] five and the kind of
Johnny Appleseed to the high five at the same time.
And within a few weeks of John Getting this press release,
the story was everywhere went kind of viral.
It wound up sort of all over the internet. There was some local newspapers who,
you know, picked it up, you know,
Murray state suddenly became very proud of the fact that they were the,
the home of the high five.
It became sort of part of the institutional lore and the athletic department
there.
And then you read this and you thought, what?
Uh, I thought, uh, how sad.
Ah,
how sad. How Sad. Because I knew the story of Glen Burke.
Turns out John had already been poking around into this question of who invented
the high five and he had stumbled on this photograph. You know what,
maybe I don't have it. A black and white picture. Oh yeah.
Here we go to baseball players facing each other. Afros,
huge smiles and their hands are in the air, right about to connect.
Which one of these is Glenn Burke's, a Burks Burkes,
the guy in the warm up jacket, I think he's even got his hat on backwards.
Glen Burke was a center fielder for the La Dodgers in the 70s. Big Guy.
He says he had 17 inch biceps. So I'll take his, I'll take his word for that.
The other guy in the picture is dusty Baker. He's an outfielder.
But you can tell in the picture just from the way that Glen is sort of throwing
his whole body forward that he's the one initiating the gesture. I mean,
this is a guy who was, um, you know, the soul of the Dodgers clubhouse.
They just had that type of, I'm charisma. This is Luther Davis, Glenn sister.
With Glenn. It was like, oh, he'd always be on a stage,
often said he should have been a comedian. Yeah,
he was always dancing around in the, in the club as he,
he used to do a Richard Pryor stand up routines
from memory. You just genuinely love people so much.
So she says that in the year that picture was taken, the Dodgers made him the,
they're sort of public face of the team. He was their ambassador of goodwill.
He's the guy, they'd say that to all the press events, you know,
like meet the youngsters and stuff. Here's the story about this picture.
What was the date? October 5th politically enough,
1977 to playoffs,
Dodgers versus Phillies game four bases are loaded.
Dusty Baker stepped up to the plate and
[inaudible]
grand slam crowd goes nuts.
Baker does his victory lap and just disease around in 30 come into the plate.
Bear comes racing out of the dugout and he's got his arm really high up in Baker
season. Instinctively raises his arm and before you know it, Burke and Baker,
smack hands,
Bam. There, it was the sportscasters that you know,
announcing the game said they had never seen that done in sports before.
And from there on the Dodgers started high fiving and everyone else started
high-fiving and the high five became a thing
and it all began with at one moment the platonic high five right there.
Unfortunately that moment that was actually both the beginning and also almost
the end of Burke's career. It's not that he wasn't good,
he was actually really good. Even in his rookie season,
he was being talked about as the next Billy Mays by the Dodgers organization.
But uh, he was gay
and he tried to keep that a secret while he was playing a dusty baker actually
had kept trying to set him up with his wife's cousins and a Burke never won,
you know, never liked any of them.
And Baker's completely confused because he knew that, you know, these were,
these were really good looking women apparently.
So there were rumors circulating and the rumors reached the front office of,
of the La Dodgers. And,
and one day Burke was called in by management and they offered him $75,000 to
get married. [inaudible] 75,000 to get married. Huh?
What is this like the mob or something? Well, exactly. I mean, no,
they didn't regularly offer their players money to get to get married.
And Burke's response apparently was a, he said, I suppose you mean to a woman?
Shortly after that the Dodgers traded into the Oakland days for a player who
everyone acknowledged was completely inferior.
That was confusing for us. And I know it had to be confusing for him.
It was shocking. And everyone, no one understood why he was traded.
And you think it was because he was gay. Yeah.
You know, baseball is all American sport. Yeah. But you know,
at least he was still going to be able to play ball or at least he thought he
ends up in Oakland, doesn't get very much playing time.
And when he did get on the field, it wasn't very pleasant.
He used to get heckled a lot, you know, from people in the bleachers. And, uh,
and even according to a couple of different people,
his coach Billy Martin would often introduce Glenn Burke this way.
This is Glenn Burke, the Fagen Greeley. Yeah. And, uh,
so Glenn Burke retires. Wow. And he was only like 26 or something, right? Yes.
He was young within a year of his rookie season just walks away. God,
that's like this aborted career. Exactly. From there, he ends up in a,
the Castro district in San Francisco,
which is the big gay neighborhood and things go okay for awhile.
But then one day when he's crossing the street,
three teenage girls and their mother's car come barreling down the road and um,
they hit him and broke his leg in three places and that kind of ended
everything. When that happened, he started taking painkillers.
One thing leads to another. He gets hooked on crack, can't hold a job,
he goes broke, ends up living on the street.
And uh, in 1994, Burke, uh, is diagnosed with,
with HIV or aids, I guess aids at that point.
He ended up coming to live with me
[inaudible]
lot of times he didn't sleep well at night and we would sit up and talk
put on music and I dance and he move his arms around cause he was in the bed.
He was bed ridden.
[inaudible]
and so you took care of him until he died? Yeah.
Glenn Burke died in 1995
[inaudible]
but what he's left with out at this point is he's left with the original high
five right? That's his claim. Yes. Yes.
That defined him to some people at least at the, at the end. And He,
and he believed it. A reporter had asked him, you know,
if it was true about the high five. And he said, yeah,
think about the feeling you get when you give someone the high five.
I had that feeling before. Everybody else did. Huh?
So what did you do when you got this press release?
So I called national high five day because I wanted to talk to Lamont sleets
even though I was sad, it seemed like, okay,
here's another person's prideful accomplishment. Let's get his story. Hello,
hello. Eventually. Hey, there we go. He gets this guy on the phone. Uh,
my name is Greg [inaudible] Ledge.
Greg is one of the founders and he and John Get to talking and John asks him the
sensible first question is the Lamont Sleet story true? He figured it was,
but you know, he thought he should at least ask.
You said a reporter and there was a pause and he said, no.
Frankly we've been waiting for someone to ask. We thought no one would ever ask.
It's not true. It's just something that we had made up.
We've learned to see if the media would, would run with it.
They made the whole thing.
They made the whole thing up and then they just went to go cast their
protagonists. So we sat down,
we picked a Murray state that's just kind of a great sounding school.
It pops up in the NCAA tournament every few years and they came across this guy,
Lamont sleet. Why him? They, well, it was pretty close to random.
They then told me they had received an email from Lamont's leads his wife.
Absolutely.
His wife emailed us and said some of the details that you have or are flat out
wrong, that implies that some of the things you've said are though,
but Lamont thinks he probably did invent the high five.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What about Glenn? I was Kinda like, hmm.
Kinda a bit blown away, you know? Yeah.
You know,
here was this guy who is proud of this and these guys just kind of stripped it
away from him.
Do you feel a little guilty? Did I mean like, okay, it's a high five.
It's kind of a silly thing. On the other hand, this guy's life, the way he died.
Do you feel like you robbed him? We do feel, we do feel,
we wish that we had done things slightly differently and,
and putting together this sort of, uh, collegiate prank,
but we didn't really know of Glenn Burke at that time.
Greg says they hadn't heard of the Glenbrook story when they pulled this prank
and now that they know it, they really feel bad. Both Derek, in fact,
they're now organizing a charity event.
They're calling the national high five Athon,
which will raise money for charity,
including one chosen by Glen Burke's sister Luther. Very proud.
Anytime I see somebody do a high five it just really makes me happy.
And that seemed like a good end of the story, but a no,
because then John told us that if you really honestly want to get to the bottom
of who invented the high five, I mean we didn't think we wanted to,
but now that we're in it, what the hell? Well,
you've got to go beyond Glen Burke Story.
I've wanted you to believe that he was the hero.
So maybe I should tell you a little bit about Derek Smith, right?
Even though Glenn Burke died believing that the high five was his legacy,
that more or less
the same moment that he invented it, a guy named Derek Smith,
a basketball player for the Louisville Cargill's,
was that practice and a guy named Wylie Brown went up to Derek Smith and was
going to give them just a ordinary low five and Derek Smith looked him in the
eye. This is what Wylie Brown told me.
Derek Smith looked him in the eye and said, no up high
[inaudible]
that year's Louisville team, they were, they were known as the doctors of Dunk,
you know, they're high flying team. They played above the rim. And John Says,
when Louisville played in the 1980 NCAA finals, I haven't seen it,
but apparently the broadcast, you referred actually to the high five handshake,
give him the high five man.
He felt compelled to explain it to America. Wow.
And it did at the moment the Derek Smith did it,
did an asteroid fall on his head or something? Well,
in 1996 I believe in,
in the 90s he had an undiagnosed heart condition and he just died all of a
sudden on a, on a cruise ship. What? Yes. And um,
he said explicitly the Wiley Brown,
this is something I'm going to be remembered for. You know,
our kids and our grandkids are going to talk about this and in fact their kids
and grandkids do talk about it and they're probably very proud. Bye.
That was Kathy. Then we ran into this woman. You'll love fireworks.
This is Kathy Gregory.
She coached women's volleyball in the 1960s years before Glenn Burke and Derek
Smith. And she says with her girls,
one did it all the time.
So I do believe that was volleyball that first started it.
And interestingly she says they would high five more when a player screwed up.
Yes. No, no.
It isn't just about celebration cause really when do you need a high five?
Of course it's more when you're doubt. Yeah, it makes people
so happy. So women's volleyball, there you go. I know Obama, Malcolm d no snip
because then I produce you.
And then Levy also discovered that in the movie breathless in 1955 and exactly
one hour, 18 minutes into the filming,
we'll see two Frenchmen do a very distinct route to sank ego right there.
Isn't this all like an indication to you that did it?
It's maybe it's one of those things that probably was there that dawn man
because it like gives pleasure.
It's just like from an evolutionary point of view. I don't think so. I think,
I think this has the feeling of something that was born. I mean,
who in this room wants Glenbrook to be the original guy? Raise your hand. Yeah,
meet me here. It's the better story. So look at what's happening here.
Every time we look for the original of anything, be it a disease,
I contagion a gesture. We find more than one.
So what are you doing in his situation? What you do is you just choose. You say,
which one is the better story? Let's just go with the best high five.
Forget the first the best. And I think we can do that. Let's just call it
Glen Dark. Glenn Burke invented the high five, high five.